let's think about exponents with ones
and zeroes so let's take the number one
and let's raise it to the 8th power so
we've already seen that there's two ways
of thinking about this you could
literally view this as taking eight ones
and then multiplying them together so
let's do that so you have one two three
four five six seven eight ones and then
you're going to multiply them together
and if you were to do that you would get
well one times one is one times one it
doesn't matter how many times you
multiply one by one you are going to
just get one you are just going to get
one and you could imagine I did it eight
times I multiplied eight ones but even
if this was 80 or if this is 800 or if
this was eight million if I just
multiplied one if I had eight million
ones and I multiplied them all together
it would still be equal to one so 1 to
any power is just going to be equal to
one and would say hey what about 1 to
the 0th power 1 to the 0th power well
we've already said anything to the zero
power except for zero that's we're going
to it's actually up for debate but
anything to the zero power is going to
be equal to one and just as a little bit
of intuition here you could literally
view this as our other definition of
exponent X potentiation which is you
start with the 1 and this number says
how many times you're going to multiply
that 1 times this number so 1 times 1 0
times is just going to be 1 and that was
a little bit clearer when we did it like
this where we said 2 to the let's say
fourth power 2 to the fourth power is
equal to this was the other definition
of exponentiation we had which is you
start with a 1 and then you multiply it
by 2 4 times so times 2 times 2 times 2
times 2 which is equal to let's see this
is equal to 16 so here if you start with
a 1 and then you multiply it by 1 0
times you're still going to have that
one right over there that's why anything
that's not 0 to the 1 power is going to
be equal to 1 now let's try some other
interesting scenarios let's start try
some negative
numbers so let's take negative 1 and
let's first raise it let's first raise
it to the zero power so once again this
is just going based on this definition
this is starting with a 1 and then
multiplying it by this number zero times
well that means we're just not going to
multiply it by this number so you're
just going to get a 1 let's try negative
1 let's try negative 1 to the first
power well anything to the first power
you could view this and I like going
with this definition as opposed to this
one right over here if we were to make
them consistent if you were to make this
definition consistent with this you
would say hey let's start with a 1 and
then multiply it by 1 8 times and you're
still going to get a 1 right over here
but let's do this with a negative 1 so
we're going to start with a 1 and then
we're going to multiply it by negative 1
one time times negative 1 and this is of
course going to be equal to negative 1
now let's take negative 1 and let's take
it to the second power we often say that
we are squaring it when we take
something to the second power so
negative 1 to the second power well we
could start with a 1 we could start with
a 1 and then multiply it by negative 1/2
times multiply it by negative 1 multiply
it by negative 1 twice and what's this
going to be equal to and once again by
our old definition you could also just
say hey ignoring this one because that's
not going to change the value we took
two negative ones and we're multiplying
them well negative 1 times negative 1 is
1 and I think you see a pattern forming
let's take negative 1
let's take negative 1 to the third power
to the 3rd power
what's this going to be equal to well by
this definition you start with a 1 and
then you multiply it by negative 1 3
times so negative 1 times negative 1
times negative 1 or you could just think
of it as you're taking 3 negative ones
and you're multiplying it because this
one doesn't change the value and this is
going to be equal to negative 1 times
negative 1 is positive 1 times negative
1 is negative 1 so you see the pattern 1
negative 1 to the 0 power is 1 negative
1 of the first power is negative 1 then
you multiply by negative 1 and getting
it positive
one then you multiply by negative one
again to get negative one and the
pattern you might be seeing is is if you
take negative one to an odd power to an
odd power you're going to get negative
one and if you take it to an even power
you're going to get one you're going to
get one because of negative times a
negative is going to be the positive and
you're gonna have an even number of
negatives so that you're always going to
have negative times negatives so this
right over here this is even even is
going to be positive one and you can see
that if you went to negative one to the
fourth power negative one to the fourth
power well you could start with a 1 and
then multiply it by negative one four
times
so negative 1 times negative one times
negative one times negative one which is
just going to be equal to positive one
so if someone were to ask you if someone
were to ask you we already established
that if you someone were to take one to
the I don't know one millionth power to
the one millionth power this is just
going to be equal to one it's just going
to be equal to one if someone told you
let's take negative one and raise it to
the 1 millionth power one millionth
power well 1 million is an even number
so this is still going to be equal to
positive one but if you took negative
one if you took negative 1 to the
999,999 power this is an odd number so
this is going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to negative one